some wage war for Gloriana we wage war
for pleasure
[Applause]
we can't wait to stir
hi everyone and welcome to another look
at Middle Earth shadow of war so I went
hands-on with the game last week and
played through a fort assault and of
course for more make sure you like and
subscribe to GameSpot but here I'm gonna
talk you through what I played so this
is our army and the benefits to having
your own army is that they can give you
things that you can take into battles so
you can have mounted cavalry or you can
have fire Drake's that you can ride but
similarly these strongholds have
defenses that you have to get past so
you have to sort of balance what you
bring compared to what you're gonna be
up against and here you get this nice
little preamble where you can talk with
talk with you guys you know they've been
with you through thick and thin and
sometimes they'll remember old battles
or if you've saved them for example
they'll remember this and they'll be
more than willing to fight for you we
can see here there's like a fiery Drake
you can just sort of see him around that
tower flying around so if you take one
of those into the battle they will
indiscriminately fire fire at either
your troops or the enemy troops so what
you have to do sort of wait until the
health has been whittled down and then
you can go in and dominate it so it's
kind of like a risk/reward thing but I
think it was so cool because it gives
you not only this amazing tactical view
of the battlefield but they're like some
really strong firepower and that was an
unintentional pun right there but here
on the ground so what you have to do as
tallien to capture the fort you and your
troops have to capture three sort of key
locations three key points which is kind
of nice and gives it some direction I
guess it's not just you going making a
straight beeline for the boss it's you
sort of taking control of the whole
thing and clearing out the bad guys so
if you take your army in what I think is
really cool is that you can actually
take a step back and let them do a hell
of a lot of damage by themselves they
can go in and they can as you can see
here take on another warlord or war
chief and just completely take them out
for you so if you are more interested in
doing other things like you can go
running point or your loot capture
points your guys can thin the herd for
you
[Music]
I love that guy's enraged by acrobatics
because who isn't so remember in shadow
of Mordor if you downed a watch if you'd
get a room that you would add to your
sword this time it's more like legendary
items it's much more of a robust RPG
system and some of them offer really
really cool perks when I played this I
actually unlocked a purple like a
legendary item which was super cool and
then I was really sad because it's not
gonna carry over into my final game but
what you can do is you can gather sets
and you can just become this unstoppable
half man/half Wraith or killing machine
so we're finally at the boss now and to
take to get all the way to him can take
anywhere from like 5 10 15 minutes
depending on how you play how many guys
you want to take out and what you can
notice here is that the attacks are a
lot more elements or so previously in
shadow model if you were to use like a
rate stun or a shadow like a wraith like
a ground pound thing it would be kind of
like a shadowy look that looked a lot
like caliber and ball but now it's like
if you pound the ground it's fire and
they can a burning status of fact or if
you stun them it's it's freezing and you
can actually see like the ice chipping
off them
which i think is really cool and it
makes it look a lot more distinct I
think that was an issue I had in the
first games that whenever caliber ball
came out you wouldn't really there's a
lot going on
another look like a little improvement
to the game that they've made here and
there so you don't have to tap r1 or
right bumper to pick up L shot anymore
you can just wander over it so that
really really makes a difference in the
game which like I'm playing it again at
the minute and tapping r1 to pick up
stuff is super annoying so you can see
here that we've taken the fort and it's
ours now and what you can do is you can
promote one your own more Chiefs to hold
it for you you might notice that it's
not really good a lot for the sneaky
players but we did ask monolith Bob
Roberts about that and he was saying
that if you're a sneaky player you can
prepare so you can sort of infiltrate
the fort before you make your assault
and you can set up traps and turn
enemies to your side before you even go
in so it's quite a cool balanced side
down and have time to do that for myself
but I can see myself playing like that
because otherwise it's just you know
like manic sword on sword action overall
there's a ton of little improvements
like the like the ultra thing I just
mentioned combat feels nice it feels
fluid I'm excited to see more they're
gonna have some big announcements at e3
so for more on shadow of war make sure
you stay tuned to get spot